foreign
[Music]
leaders are coming together to discuss
the climate crisis at an annual Summit
for our politicians doing enough to save
the planet do you think it's too late to
stop global warming
floods are happening more frequently you
need to do something about it very
quickly otherwise it will become more
serious we've only got one planet what
are the solutions and what can we do to
help
we can do this guys but we got to make
changes now in this special edition of
FYI we have a unique survey that reveals
in detail what people our age really
think about the climate crisis
hi there so as world leaders gather
together to discuss climate change at
cop 27 we thought that we'd have a big
discussion about it too yeah but first
what is cop27 well we found out it
stands for Conference of parties and
it's where world leaders come together
to discuss action to tackle climate
change
cop1 took place in Germany back in 1995.
so has there actually been any progress
well Greta timberg has said she's not
going to cop27 which is in Egypt because
she thinks it's a waste of time this is
no longer a climate conference this is
now a global North Green wash Festival
a two-week long celebration of business
as usual and blah blah blah
but why does Greta think this in Glasgow
last year world leaders agreed to cut
down on the use of coal a fossil fuel
that produces global warming gases but
some countries refuse to do that
and many countries agree to protect our
forests which soak up those gases
including Brazil but then the
destruction of its Amazon rainforest
reached record levels
what we really wanted to know what you
think about climate change in efforts to
save our planet so FYI and sky kids
carried out a survey of 2007 to 14 year
olds and Braden's been looking at the
findings
[Music]
we all know that our planet is under
threat from climate change but this is
the first time that we've been able to
analyze in detail what people our age
really think about it fyi's major survey
questioned 2 000 kids in the UK aged
between 7 and 14 years old and wait for
it 43 of us said that climate change is
the biggest issue facing the world right
now
it's not hard to understand why our
climate is changing in a dramatic way
with more and more extreme weather as
well as droughts floods and wildfires
the survey's findings show that 50 of us
are scared by news about climate change
but 33 percent of us say we're inspired
to take action to save the planet
interestingly it seems we don't always
talk about it with the people we trust
with only eight percent learning about
climate change from their friends and
family
so what about the role of our schools in
letting us know about the climate crisis
and inspiring us to do more well there's
mixed news on this because 53 of you
said that school is where you get most
of your information however 81 of you
guys said that you want to be taught
more about the climate crisis at school
that suggests that we're not learning
enough about it in the classroom the
government has promised to introduce a
new GCSE course in England by 2025 which
will cover the climate crisis and just
recently a new batch of teachers have
completed their training to teach us
more about climate change but when we
asked if the government is doing enough
to help save our planet look at this
only 10 said yes some really interesting
points there more on the survey later
but now we've got the environmentalist
Bella lacking to see what she thinks
hi Pella hi thanks for having me so it's
clear from the survey that young people
think that climate change is a big issue
it scares the young people who filled in
the survey they feel as if the
government isn't doing enough and you
think after making so many promises to
deal with it that wouldn't be the case
yeah I think it's not only that the
government's not doing enough they're
actually reversing some of the pledges
they made last year at cop 26 which is
this massive climate conference and it
was in Glasgow so it was kind of the
UK's big responsibility to do everything
we can
um and then just when Liz trust got into
being prime minister she actually gave
licenses for a hundred oil and gas rigs
which kind of completely defeats the
whole purpose of this meeting we had
last year so yeah they're not just not
doing enough they're actually going
backwards on their promises definitely I
mean it's so annoying seeing promises
being made and getting expectations that
is going to get better and then it just
doesn't happen and as for us very few of
us seem to be discussing the climate
crisis with friends or family does that
surprise you it does surprise me
um I think though it's less about how
much we speak about the climate crisis
and more what we say about it and when
we come out of those conversations do we
feel like we can do something
um and another thing is we shouldn't be
just be kind of agreeing with each other
we need to chat to people who challenge
us who we can challenge and kind of
spread ideas and awareness rather than
just staying in our comfort zone and
agreeing with each other yeah definitely
yes young people are chatting out
standing up there mobilizing like never
before but I think if we were taught
about it say in year one year two
imagine how many more years we could
have of young people beginning to learn
beginning to take action at school I
only had one assembly about climate
change and it made me realize how much
of a serious issue it is and I think it
just shows that you know if kids start
learning about it sooner then it can
make a huge difference so last year you
spent a year interviewing young people
affected by climate change for a book so
did they have hope for the future
um I think it's an interesting one
because hope shouldn't really be a noun
I think hope is something which we have
to create for ourselves and all the
young people I talked to were doing
something so I think what I learned is
that
um you know once you know what the
problem is and once you have the passion
to do something about it that's all you
need and you can definitely make a
change it's really good advice and thank
you for coming in today thanks for
having me thank you so much coming up on
your Weekly News show from Britain's Got
Talent finalists to presenter of a sky
kids documentary we hear from the
environmentalist anishwa about his six
ways to save our planet
but right now we're going to hear more
about what you want world leaders to do
at cop27 well actually turning up is a
start when our prime minister Rishi
sunak announced he wasn't going to the
conference environmental Charities
demanded he had a rethink so now he's
announced that he is going right well we
invited some FY news club members to
send in their messages for world leaders
[Music]
dear world leaders
we need to start taking action I think
that you as world leaders aren't doing
enough for the planet I think you are
trying to help but you're just not doing
it enough sometimes I feel like you and
the world leaders feel like there's
another planet to go to but there is
none there's no plan B's so that's going
to have to sort it out it's my
generation so I think you're being
really selfish and not listening to us
you need to step up your game and the
floods are happening more frequently you
need to do something about it very
quickly otherwise it will become more
serious if we need a healthy will to
inherit before it gets out of hand and
to the point where we can't fix it
anymore because we've only got one
planet
and if you want your saying on FYI then
why not get your school to set up an FYI
News Club get your teachers head to our
website for more details earlier Braden
told us about some of the findings of
our major sky kids FYI survey about what
people our age think about climate
change
we heard that 50 of us get scared when
we hear about climate change and only 10
of us think the government is doing
enough to help tackle the climate crisis
but it's not all bad news here's Braden
again
[Music]
we're often told that time is running
out to save our planet
4. the 2007 to 14 year olds questioned
in our survey took a more positive View
63 percent of us said it's not too late
to save our planet with just 10 saying
it is too late and loads of us have had
big ideas about what we can do to take
action our survey team had hundreds of
responses and there's just a few ideas
that you guys gave us recycle more of
the things we use use electric cars
instead of petrol and Diesel grow your
own fruit and vegetables all homes to
have solar panels plant more trees put
on a jumper before you turn on the
heating to save electricity
uh maybe not that one but what are we
already doing to try and help with the
climate crisis well 89 of us say we try
and recycle 82 percent of us so we turn
off the lights to save electricity 62
percent of us say we cycle or walk to
school and 27 percent of us so we eat
less meat than we used to so overall it
seems most of us are doing our best to
try and make a difference and we're
still optimistic that it's not too late
to save our planet
nice one Braden and for some inspiration
on what can be done to beat the climate
crisis check out a new sky kids
documentary cop 27 six ways to save our
planet we had a sneak preview
we're all so lucky that this is our home
a place where creatures are free to roam
but the climate is changing because of
pollution
and it's up to us to find a solution
United has won our ideas to share
and you can help too because we all care
the film is a mind-blowing journey
across six continents with a nichewa
looking at six ways to save the planet
helping me out I have five friends
around the world we're gonna start in
Kenya in Africa
in Kenya award-winning environmentalist
eliane searches for solutions to beat
drought and famine
here I organize events to get lots of
people to buy seeds and plant trees
they help soak up climate changing gases
like carbon dioxide produced by cars and
power stations
when the world leaders announced the
next climate change Summit cop 27 was to
be held in Africa in Egypt I was glad
because they need to listen up
from life-saving farming in Africa
to Europe's super greenhouses
this one
Greener transport on a massive scale in
South America
Asia can pollution be reduced by
bringing nature into the city
it's like a high-tech Tropical Paradise
from the air we see super solar farms in
Australia
and in North America a glimpse into the
future
yes floating cities as sea levels rise
we can do can disguise but we got to
make changes now
[Applause]
well you might recognize the presenter
of that documentary anishwa he got to
the finals of Britain's Got Talent with
his climate change poetry Hi anishwa how
are you hello I'm really good
well can you tell us a bit more about
your documentary I mean it looks
brilliant we have been thinking about
ways to save the planet just like using
solar panels and wind turbines to make
our natural resources like air and
sunlight into electricity instead of
using fuel what can actually harm the
planet a lot as well as planting a lot
and lots of trees in our cities to soak
up harmful gases I want world leaders to
watch this because this is quite
important and it may give world leaders
some ideas to help the Save the Planet
well you managed to get your voice heard
on Britain's Got Talent and now you've
got your sky kids documentary which is
great but what else can we do to save
the planet we need to do little
steps to make a big difference to our
planet and we should keep on speaking
out well I think maybe we can plant more
of our food at home and by walking going
by public transports or going by bike or
scooter can be better and more
eco-friendly than taking a lift by your
mom or dad's car what can produce lots
of carbon dioxide which is bad for the
environment did you have fun making the
film yes I have lots of fun well it's
been great speaking to you bye bye and
thank you and you can see cop27 six ways
to save our planet on sky kids and Sky
News and there's loads of resources for
schools via our webpage
[Music]
earlier we mentioned that despite Brazil
promising to stop the destruction of the
Amazon rainforest president bolzinaro
went on to allow record number of trees
to be chopped down for things like
farming and wood
well some good news it seems the country
has just had a presidential election and
this man they call him Lula has won and
he promises to protect the Amazon
rainforest well fingers crossed he keeps
his promises yeah hey Maya I thought
this was fake news when I first saw it
did you know that some local authorities
have canceled bonfire night celebrations
oh really why well to save money really
with things getting so expensive some
councils have had to cut back on the
amount of money they've been spending
and even though that may be
disappointing check this out I read it
in a report by scientists bonfires
sparklers and fireworks release a lot of
pollution in a short space of time
including chemicals that contribute to
global warming and plastic and metal
particles that harm Wildlife but I guess
the less of them there are the better it
is for the planet absolutely
so in a special edition of FYI we found
out about loads of things that we're all
doing to help tackle the climate crisis
even though we are worried about the
future and feel more can be done we are
taking action
so we thought we leave you some of our
favorite images of the planet to remind
us all that it really is worth saving
see you next time
[Music]